It's easy in 3JS to hook up the mouse, keyboard, and other devices as
interactive controls for objects in a scene. We've been doing this all along
with demos such as the robot arm. There's much JavaScript code to draw upon for
getting inputs connected to programs, such as the dat.gui library for sliders.
However, up to this point we've had little direct interaction with our virtual
worlds. By direct interaction I mean using the mouse to click on the world
itself and change its appearance. The main direct interaction so far has been
using the mouse to move the camera. As an example of another direct interaction
in this demo by Max Ogden and James Halliday I'm clicking to remove blocks or
add them. Programs can be seen limiting without these sorts of direct
interactions with what the user sees. Even when moving around the scene with
the mouse, in many demos it says if we're a ghost, we can walk through walls or
drop through the floor, there's nothing stopping us. By instead performing
what's called collision detection between objects, and having the program
respond to those collisions, we can create a more believable world. We can also
use physics to determine how our actions and the movements of other objects
change what we see. If you've played any computer game, you know how various
button pushes and so on are tightly tied to what you see on the screen. How the
world reacts to inputs such as these is often shown through animation
techniques of one sort of another. Up to this point, we've mostly been ignoring
this fourth dimension, time. Once we start changing elements in our scene over
time, we're performing animation. Animations can also be run in their own
right. Streams flow down a hillside. People walk past you in a marketplace. The
sun sets over ocean waves. Animation, such as shown in this demo by Daniel
Heat, gives a scene life and a sense of engagement even when there's little
interaction. What I'm going to cover in this unit is a sampling of interaction
and animation techniques. So let's get going.